kids killed kids
it's not fun and so desensitizes what we
have to do because that is our job
it's a job
against that wall with excellent and i
have all my veterans
the other wall on this side i'm gonna
have all my incentives
the military rain watches its soldiers
oh wow um i don't think the natural
inclination for a human being is to want
to kill
another human being there is a necessary
requirement in the military
to get you to perform a certain action
and in order for that action to occur it
is my
theory that there is a part of changing
the way that you think
in order to take somebody from a human
being and make it a target so that you
can achieve a goal everybody else come
on in
they had asked are the military
desensitizing soldiers
are they manipulating them
mentally and i would have walked over
here i would have walked over here too
brainwashing well i don't know man it's
just like i even watch like the
advertisements for the military and it
just seems to me
the one thing you brought up was was
killing
um it's no no one wants to do it i know
i don't want to do it
i didn't want to flips you if you have
something yes you use the words
desensitized
we're desensitizing ourselves because we
have to we have to move on
i just think that that's kind of my
point though in order to get from that
spot where you don't want to kill
another human being
to where you look at it as this is just
my job but it's a choice
yeah and it's not brainwashing it really
just comes down to either that guy
at the end of your muzzle or you and i
want to come back home to my family
war is a necessary evil
okay
yeah this is a tough one
i think that there's a point between a
just
war and an unjust war
there are certain wars that um you know
maybe we should have gone
into like maybe we shouldn't have gone
into iraq right right
and then there's certain wars where
world war ii
you know where hitler was advancing to
poland
i think that's definitely a just war to
get into i mean he is trying to
kill jewish people yeah and in that case
you could call it a necessary evil there
is a time that that necessary evil
has to happen and in that you don't even
maybe call it a necessary evil it's just
a necessity
the action itself has to take place
as long as we leave this on the table at
war as a necessary evil it really just
excuses
almost all you know all wars because if
it's
what's excusable right when does it
become necessary if you really want to
see
a peaceful world you have to just get
rid of that because the key word there
is
isn't necessary necessary i don't
believe that i don't believe it's
necessary
that it's the only way for to you to
obtain
your objective is war that's the reason
why
i thought you were disagreeing with evil
no no no no i mean well
yeah war is not evil i mean uh not
yeah it's not um have you ever had an
argument
but you had good intentions of course
right so
yeah to speak on the word evil i don't
really agree that
war equals evil as well
world peace is possible
probable maybe not possible yes
when you get humans together and find a
way to find
common ground to find the similarities
rather than the differences
that's when you have a possibility at
peace and i believe
that it is something that is possible on
a grand scale is it easy
maybe not but it is possible
world peace i want that to happen of
course
um but it's so much easier said than
done
i think because just the way that we
were taught you know we all want world
peace
but let's say a culture in africa thinks
that genital mutilation is
perfectly fine are we going to be
perfectly fine with that are we going to
be able to talk them out of it i don't
really think we are because they have
their own customs their own culture so
the only way
we can kind of get them to accept our
culture is through some sort of violence
that's dangerous i do believe that the
quantum of people that would prefer
peace to conflict is is growing
and that's what gives me hope
yeah of course
so if it meant if i died the world would
be at peace
well yeah look i've i've had
some amazing adventures on planet earth
i've had the greatest of friends the
greatest of family seen the best
concerts
uh seen some beautiful places if it
meant that
that happened for this place to be
a-okay groovy do it right now
i had a good run i got 35 years that's
more than a lot
uh i've got more than twice yeah those
years
but more importantly i have two
grandchildren
and a third one on the way yeah and and
really i had to think about it
but if i could do that and bring them
world peace let alone all the
lexi's and charlie's around the world
that's easy and like life is so
beautiful but for me i believe there is
a life after my life and there are many
lifetimes
yeah if i had to die for world peace
it's me versus
seven billion human beings like it's not
even a question
initially when i heard the question i
thought man what a dumb question and
then steve
your answer actually really made me
think oh well i actually elicited like a
really beautiful response when you're
talking about your grandchildren
you know and then i heard some then i'll
think a little bit more about this
question and i realized you know what
if i say i'm willing to die for peace
well gosh when's the last time i did
anything to actually promote peace so
i'd be like wow i'd be really
full of [ __ ] if i said that i'd be
willing to die for peace i wouldn't be
able to
even take the most basic steps towards
actually contributing something to it
but those basic those basic steps
totally matter
um but also living a life of purpose is
a
life that's lived moment to moment to
moment so simply you
by being you you affect people like i
you see my
only met you for what half an hour 45
minutes you got a good head on your
shoulders and
wherever you go you leave an imprint
that's true for all of us
i mean don't get me wrong i don't want
to die and i'd rather do those things
i i'm in a i'm in a peace group that has
met
every friday morning since 9 11
16 years for two hours
every friday to work on these issues so
i think really if we i sometimes say
a dollar a day and an hour a day
i know someone who has died
yeah i know a lot of i mean not like
tons of people was you know
a dozen or so people but my closest
friend who killed uh was killed was
his name was chris domay and he had a
wife and kids it was uh
is uh pretty sad i've deployed seven
times now and i'm scheduled to go back
out in march
uh from my eighth back to afghanistan
but uh i think there was probably one or
two deployments where we didn't
uh lose someone so i don't know if it's
appropriate what taps into your
courage to keep going back in the face
of losing
these guys yeah it's uh for me it's not
only just
a job when i say job i think of family i
think of putting foot on the table
roof over the head of my family and then
second to that or pretty much tied for
first is
the guys next to you you know i went to
high school out here in l.a and
really didn't have a future in college
or anything just we grew up poor and
homeless at some points but uh joining
military want to serve my country and
really just
uh have something stable and as it
evolved it was now like this big family
you're part of you're part of something
that's bigger and
i don't mind uh deploying because i know
i'm with family
i think i'm blessed that i don't know
anybody who's died in combat so
i mean yeah i don't understand
what you guys have been through but i
applaud you
all of you guys for like you said
putting foot on the table because in my
head i was like
there's so many jobs out there why this
one
when you're when you're a soldier you're
you're making a sacrifice
so thank you by the way you're welcome
yeah you know i mean i think and i think
as americans we appreciate anybody who
makes a significant sacrifice
it's kind of the ultimate sacrifice yeah
i'm not kidding we're done
so so this this this exceeded
thank you for checking out that video
much appreciation
we get to do what we love because you
all watch our videos so
if you really love us you'll continue to
keep watching videos there's more right
here that you can check out you probably
haven't seen all of them
and if you really want to just commit to
us you can subscribe right here
i'll be around i'll be at the end of
some more videos and i will keep in
touch
peace